hi there I'm Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big thing
podcast since 2008 big think has been
bringing you big ideas in small
concentrated doses from some of the most
creative thinkers around on the think
again podcast we step outside of our
comfort zone surprising our guests on me
your host with ideas that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss based on interview clips from
our archives chosen by our producers
today I am very very happy to be here
with James Glick he is one of our most
staggeringly great living science
writers he's the author of the
information a history a theory of flood
his first book chaos was the National
Book Award and Pulitzer Prize finalist
and the national bestseller his other
books include the best-selling
biographies genius the life and science
of Richard Fineman and Isaac Newton both
shortlisted for the Pulitzer Prize
James's new book time travel a history
is an utterly fascinating journey
through the history of an idea that has
become part of the fabric of philosophy
science and our daily lives even though
we can't really do it yet not really
welcome to think again James Thank You
Jason I'm happy to be here I'm so happy
to have you I wanted to start with a
little anecdote like walking here
walking a couple of days ago toward Big
Think reading your book because I'm like
one of the last ridiculous humans who
walks down the street in a busy city
reading a book I nearly ran into a bus
and there was an advertisement on the
side of the bus for a television show
called timeless protect the past save
the future so I thought you know that
that's just one of a whole slew of
television shows that are starting this
fall on the theme of time travel really
yes are we in that time-travel
Renaissance maybe we are I didn't I
didn't think so actually when I started
working on the book in fact there was a
time when I thought and this is a crazy
idea so I'm a little embarrassed to be
admitting this okay so you can edit it
out if you and I actually thought maybe
time-travel is coming to an end
maybe the golden era of time-travel has
run its course because we've imagined
all of the things well yeah
that turned out not to be true and all I
was working on the book all this there
were some great time-travel movies and
Doctor Who continues to thrive I don't
think we'll ever tire of time travel
especially as like physics progresses
unless we get to a point where someone
can definitively say to us sorry bub
that's never gonna happen
you know right well I'm prepared to say
that okay if we want to just you know
yeah let's put it out he'll kill the bus
right yeah but actually I get just sort
of contradict the premise of my book
because the whole point is that our
excitement about exploring all the weird
possibilities at the time offers us has
never been as lively as now and so I
should be saying that it makes perfect
sense that there are a whole bunch of
new network TV shows about time travel
can you identify any kind of like
cultural trigger point why there might
be a ton of shows right now about time
travel is there something that happened
recently or is this just the pendulum of
media swinging it's not just now there
was a time when that question was right
on point
and unfortunately that time was 1895
when HG Wells wrote The Time Machine
which is kind of the beginning of the
whole story right so when you asked me
that question I want to I know you're
asking about now and I can and I'll get
back to now but when you talk about
cultural trigger points that's exactly
what there was I mean at least that's
exactly the question that I that I
wanted to try to answer I mean why if no
one had thought about time travel as an
idea before was it suddenly possible for
HG Wells to create this powerful fantasy
and I should jump in here and say that
your book makes the surprising but
evidently very well researched claim
that indeed HG Wells essentially
invented the idea of time travel that it
barely shows up before the book the time
machine yeah it was a surprise to me and
I'm and I'm still prepared to be
defensive about it because because
everyone's first reaction seems to be
wait that can't possibly be true well
yeah what about the ancient Greeks
didn't they you know at least think
about what about the future
well it's you know it's a tricky
question of course
you think about the future and you have
fortune tellers that's there's hardly
any cultural tradition that's older than
that can you predict what's gonna happen
to me
soothsayers and diviners and and all of
that but most of the time you discover
that people are wondering about their
own future right you know you want to
know am I gonna live a happy life what
they were not capable of asking was how
is the world going to be different for
my grandchildren what wonderful things
will they experience and surround
themselves with that don't exist in the
present so that brings us to
technological advancement and also the
concept of culture as a whole
exactly yeah yeah I mean you have to
have technological change accelerating
to a kind of critical point where a
person can look around the landscape and
see trains whizzing by where there
didn't used to be where there used to
just be farmland and realized that this
newfangled electric telegraph is really
altering people's living habits right
and then you start to ask well gee could
things be different what land and you
ask what marbles will the future bring
right and and that's what happened and
so I explore the history of that a
little bit but now I mean because you
asked yeah yeah about know now think now
it's very different because we're so
used to it we're so familiar with it we
know all about time travel we're kind of
experts all right from from the cradle
so it's interesting to me that people
keep finding new variations yeah I mean
even my eight-year-old son has come up
with a essentially incomprehensible but
I've probed it I don't get it but it's a
paradox that he seems to think is
coherent about time travel where he's
like oh if I went back in time and then
but the best I can understand is that he
thinks that time travel is some kind of
virtual reality machine where you're
actually it's just amassed all the data
from everything that's ever happened and
so when you go back you're creating new
data and then you're it's a very crazy
well that sounds he said in very
advanced
indeed I can't I can't quite get to the
bottom of what exactly the paradise but
he's on to something there you're on to
something I think and and maybe this is
part of the real answer to your question
which is we know that that the
technological change that we're
experiencing is all bound up with
virtualization with networking with
cyberspace with data transmission right
we experience different parts of the
world virtually on our screens of all
sizes and more and more this is also
affecting our sense of time we
experience the past on the same screens
that bring us the present if we see a
video of something in terrific
high-resolution it may not be something
that's happening now it may be something
that happened a very long time ago now
if it's a hundred years ago right you
can tell because it's grainy or black
and white but more and more there's a
kind of confusion about time that I
think has to do with data transmission
so I think your son's on to something
there but and it's also the case that
science fiction writers are playing with
that and this becomes the end of my book
I didn't know while I was working on
what the end was gonna be I mean Isis
right I'm always afraid that my books
are just gonna peter out but I was also
aware that some weird things are
happening in our culture to do with our
understanding of time and I don't
understand them all I don't think any of
any of us understand them but to frame
it just slightly differently differently
from looking at the past through screens
another thing that's happening is you
get a text message and you get an email
and you see a note on Twitter all from
the same person and maybe you're meeting
somebody and you have to check did the
email come before the text message and
you start thinking about the time stamps
and you can get confused in daily life
I'm sure examples come to your mind yes
I'm sure they come to your
eight-year-olds mine so what's
interesting is right on the one hand as
I as I listen to you talk about this I'm
thinking okay so that's creating a kind
of a historicity like the young people
won't
- Sara we know when things are from
because everything is present
simultaneously side by side but at the
same time it seems advanced
philosophically in terms of things that
you talked about in your book in terms
of the idea that some philosophers and I
think even Einstein may have said that
time time becomes less of a significant
force somehow and it's a paradox it's
yet another of the time travel paradoxes
that you're right it's a kind of a
historicity in the sense that everything
gets muddled together in world were just
living in a very complicated extended
present right and what time a thing is
from almost doesn't matter and
historical figures are living with us
almost as vividly as the people we
actually know right and yet conversely
you could say that that's a kind of
historical awareness that's more acute
than ever that that in fact we are well
connected with the past
thus we can get Hamilton the musical in
hip hop as that people can sort of
relate I mean young people can connect
to Alexander Hamilton in a meaningful
way that they couldn't necessarily from
history book yes and but not only that
you know Alexander Hamilton has to be
translated into a somewhat fictionalized
or staged version or he has to be
translated for us in a different way but
an equally artificial way by serious
biographers by the way I don't mean to
imply that Hamilton the music is not
serious it is but we don't get to see
Hamilton right right we would actually
know what he even looked like I mean I
wrote a biography of Isaac Newton and
partway through it I realized nobody
actually has any idea what Newton looked
like there are a few portraits right but
if you line the portraits up they look
like different people because they
really were lousy painters so we have to
imagine what he looked like and then
right the truth is we're mostly
imagining what George Washington looked
like even that we have we probably think
we have a pretty vivid picture in our
head right it's it's made up but we know
exactly what FDR looked like because
we've got video you know although
arguably going back
to some other concepts in the book that
creates a kind of illusion of temporal
continuity that that isn't entirely
accurate anyway because arguably every
FDR at every moment of his life is
somewhat of a different person
well that's true okay that's it that's a
deep point but you know one way to look
at our sense of history is to is to
recognize that different media have
different time horizons and we know
about a certain segment of the past
because the printed word is available to
us and right and we know about a much
more recent segment of the past because
we've got life we've got video right and
it it is different but what I'm trying
to say is that on the one hand were
connected to the past in vivid new
useful ways and on the other hand the
past and the present are all muddled
together and right we just feel we're in
an unending present and I think you're
very right to say that we don't really
know what it means like and we certainly
aren't in a position I think to make
moral claims about it at this point to
say whether it's better or worse or
whatever like you know one thing that's
that's always motivated me is my
continuing sense of confusion or
surprise that the past is so weirdly
different from the present and a kind of
historical fiction that I really don't
like in books or in movies is a kind
that makes me think you're writing about
these people from the 16th century as
though they were modern as though they
were thinking the same way we think and
actually it's extremely difficult almost
impossible for us to put our ourselves
inside the heads of people who lived in
the 16th century for example how could
there be so many slaveholding
abolitionists at the time of the
revolution you know there were yeah many
people who were like actively fighting
against slavery while owning slaves to
put it to put it in a political or moral
way yes that's true yeah I mean it
creates sort of ethical tangles for you
if you start to think to yourself am I
supposed to forgive them because it was
a different time
and.and you do forgive them I mean
people you admire living in the past say
the most atrocious things about about
women and yet you recognize that it was
a different time
but that's but that's not all I'm saying
I'm also saying if I'm trying to write
about Isaac Newton and what he was
thinking about gravity can I subtract
from the picture everything that we know
about gravity I mean we have a kind of
intuition about gravity we can feel it
all around us hold out your arm and and
it's then there's this invisible force
that's pulling it downward and how can
we imagine a mental picture of the world
from which that is subtracted because
that's what Newton have Newton you look
up the word gravity and historical
dictionaries and you realize that before
Newton started calling it using the word
for the thing we're talking about it
meant it was a state of mind you know
gravity was the opposite of levity and
it just meant taking things seriously
right but if you want to write about the
history of science as I've tried to do
you really need to be able to put
yourself imaginatively in this weird
mindset right right which is hard one
before we get on to the surprise
conversations there was one other I want
to go back to time travel for a second
this was the surprise conversation well
the surprise conversations are sparked
by video clips of interviews from big
things archives that we don't know what
they're about so okay okay well so even
you don't know no oh I have no idea so
um they get emailed to me and I don't
look honest but the last thing I want to
say about time travel before we get
there is my problem with time travel my
personal problem with travel is that it
presupposes that the past exists he in
some way still right now like that's the
idea that just really bugs me like
everyone assumes that you or everyone
who takes the idea of time-travel
seriously is assuming that there is a
these things are some when right yeah
and you want me to help you with that
well no but I guess I guess like why
isn't that a bigger problem in the disk
time travel wine well or people seem to
have an issue with that or maybe they do
um I almost hate to reveal this the
spoiler about this I guess there's a
sort of spoiler but I'm just gonna say I
mean I think you're completely right
you're obviously right and time travel
is impossible and that's essentially why
but that's okay I mean that's now I want
to say that's alright because we we know
all along that time travel is just a
fantasy HG Wells knew that he was making
stuff up sure I mean he just wanted to
tell a fun story and accidentally in the
course of justifying - making a story
plausible he came up with a theory of
time as a fourth dimension that Einstein
also came up with ten years later right
you're exactly right
time travel presupposes that the past is
still somehow there as opposed to gone
and even worse it presupposes that the
future is already an existing place yeah
and that is contrary to our most basic
human intuition about time which I will
summarize this way the past is over it
happened it's gone right and we have no
longer have access to it and the future
has not yet happened some physicists
will tell you that yeah you feel that
way but that's just a human intuition
and human intuition has again and again
through history proved to be unreliable
and until Newton explained gravity to us
we thought that up was up and down was
down and now we're perfectly comfortable
with the fact that people in outer space
have no particular no preferred
orientation with regard to verticality
that it's a that it's a consequence of
gravity and maybe our sense of the past
in the future
is artificial in that same way now if
you ask me what I personally believe I
believe those physicists are taking
their models too seriously
that this idea of the block universe
in which the past and the future look
according to the equations of physics to
be the same is a very useful
mathematical construct incredibly useful
it's enabled physics to create the
marvels that surround us but it's just a
model of the world and we don't have to
say that it tells us definitively that
the future already exists
we are still allowed speaking
philosophically to imagine that the
future is open and you're right
that undermines the premise of most
time-travel but isn't that all right I
mean it's a story
oh it's for so long as we accept yeah
yes and and so you then it frees you to
ask what's this story telling us about
the world we really live in right you're
gonna organize a particular kind of time
travel story in which your hero keeps
getting killed and each time he gets
killed he starts over or she I'm
thinking of two different versions of
this kind of story what's that a
metaphor for why did the artist choose
to express this particular kind of weird
universe what does it tell us about the
universe we really do live in and the
artists and the culture and the time and
so yeah yeah okay well this has been so
fascinating that I've used up a ton of
our time but we may have we may end up
we may end up having only two surprised
conversations rather than three about
let's see so this is Penn Jillette on
prayer and the atheist
so let's see where that takes us
I very rarely look in this kind of
proximity but I'm not sexting if you
want to know how to be a good leader
watch Donald Trump and don't do that I
realized recently I do something very
close to prayer and I don't want to show
any disrespect to people by using the
word prayer but I also want to make a
little bit of an argument Sam Harris
makes his argument for atheist
meditation I make a little bit of an
argument for atheist prayer I do
something before I go to sleep at night
called Penn's guilt roundup and Penn's
guilt roundup is I go through
conversations that I've had like tonight
weren't before I go to bed I'll think so
I really have made that sexting joke
when I was at the big thing but I really
have done that now run through how I
could have done that better I also try
to think of what I want and how I can
get there now I'm very fortunate because
when I go to my desires there they're
not very often material material desires
because my family is well cared for but
I think about I used to think about my
weight I would pray to be able to
control the wants of my diet and I do
believe with God there's a lot of
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
I'm not too referring to baptism there
I'm referring to huh
I referring to the fact that so much of
the social and personal elements of
religion are really good I would say
maybe more than good maybe very close to
necessary
do you feel that that science is better
off for having largely thrown off
religion do you feel that it has like
advanced faster do you feel that those
scientists were hamstrung in some way by
the by the frameworks through which they
were viewing the world or as we were
just talking about just now do you think
that maybe some of these new theoretical
models that they invent are becoming a
new kind of metaphysics or a new
religious worldview that is right that's
I was gonna go a whole different way we
could go and know that you want that's
that's interesting um I'm an atheist
myself a lot of scientists are atheists
but some scientists are not atheists
Newton of course was profoundly
religious he couldn't the idea of a
universe without God it just wouldn't
have occurred to him you're asking if
science is better off for having thrown
off ideas or thrown off as a charged
phrase but yes for having many not
having them embedded in it and there is
it would be silly for me to deny that
there's a sort of conflict between
science and religion because there is
scientists characteristically view the
world in a way that is let's say more
open more waiting for evidence more
provisional than religion does at least
as I understand religion and I don't
want to pretend to be any sort of expert
on it you know some of my best friends
believe in God right and I don't think
they are any less intelligent far from
it or even any less correct about the
world than I am and so to be
intellectually honest I have to ask
myself what that means and I think I
think that's what Penn was doing when he
was talking about prayer he was asking
how can I make sense of these ideas that
are so much a part of our culture even
today so for me a thing to say about God
is to try to understand what it means to
people in a more sophisticated
stated way than just you know guy with a
beard and white hand and white hey with
a beard and white hair who knows
everything that's gonna happen or is in
charge of things or created the universe
or you know right there's obviously more
to it than that just as pan is saying
there's more to the idea of prayer than
sending a message to some powerful being
who's going to give you what you want
sure that's not what serious people
think prayer is and I think Penn is
right to try to understand a more
expansive view of what is meant by the
idea of prayer when I talk to my friends
who are as intelligent or more
intelligent than I who have a kind of
religious faith
right I endeavor to understand what how
to make sense of what that means and I
do think I have some understanding of it
Anna and I want to say this about it
that there's a different kind of
dichotomy both in religion and in
science that has to do with how we know
things and how we know what we know what
we believe about the process of arriving
at knowledge okay which is the area
formerly called in philosophy is that
epistemology maybe I know yeah I don't
even want to pretend to know what the
law servers call it what I want to what
I want to get it is I'll say
simplistically you know there are two
kinds of scientists there are scientists
who are always in a state of doubt who
considered the normal thing is just to
not know things right I mean this is I'm
thinking of richard fineman here he was
eager to say that the universe is a
mystery and that most of it is never
going to be understood by us humans and
then all we can hope for is little
glimmers of insight here and there right
I believe that there are people in the
realm of religion who have the same
attitude who have the same view of faith
right who when they speak of faith
they're not saying I know this this and
this about the origins of the universe I
know that there was
flood and I know that God did this and
that they are talking about it faith as
a twin of doubt that faith does not mean
certainty it means I am believing a
certain thing while not claiming
absolute certainty about it
I am trying to come to grips with my
sense that what we see and touch in the
universe is not all there is
right and both scientists and people of
religion do that and they do it
honorably and there are people in both
realms who I think do it less honorably
or at least I should maybe I'll say less
to my tastes guy are scientists who are
very confident in what they tell you
about the laws of physics and what they
know about things that I consider
religious questions if a scientist tells
you that he knows how the universe
started right or how the universe is
going to end I tend to think they're
overstepping their bounds and in exactly
the way that fundamentalist religious
people overstep their bounds when they
tell you that wisdom has been handed to
us in a certain book right and it must
not be questioned so faith then in the
sense of more to your taste and I will
say more to my taste sense of it is you
know faith that's oriented that's around
uncertainty but I guess hopefulness in a
sense but anyone who's doing anything
really really interesting in the world
it seems that there's some motive even
if they wouldn't articulate it as faith
that there's some kind of belief that
there's a reason to move in the
direction that they're they're going and
not to just stop doing that right isn't
it possible to argue something different
that we're just you know sort of sad
creatures who do what we do for reasons
that are not accessible to us and yes
I'm when I write my next book it will be
with a sense of purpose and a
a kind of implicit belief that there's
some value to it and who knows what my
hidden motivations but maybe it's also
possible that I'm just doing it because
it's a thing to do a thing to do yeah
okay well I think on that night before
we've dissolve into an existential suit
on that deflating note yeah let's see
what the next let's see what the next
one is this is David Eagleman
neuroscientist and it's called your
time-bending brain so this is a area of
interest to me and my labs been studying
this for a while is this is why time is
rubbery and can speed up or slow down
and the experiment had never been done
about why time seems to move in slow
motion when you're in a life-threatening
situation but I talked to so many people
and I'd experienced it myself that I
wanted to study that so I found a way to
study it by by dropping people from 150
foot tall tower and measuring their time
perception on the way down and that plus
several other experiments we did in my
lab led me to understand that people
don't actually see time in slow motion
during an event instead it's a
completely retrospective assessment in
other words when you're in a
life-threatening situation your brain
writes down memory much more densely and
then retrospectively when you look at
that you have so many details that you
don't normally have that it seems as
though it must have lasted a very long
time that's the only interpretation your
brain can make so time your assessment
of how long something took has a lot to
do with how much energy your brain has
to burn during the event and how much
footage you have of the event
okay a thing that that everybody knows
about time is that our perception of it
varies the observation that sometimes
time passes quickly and sometimes time
passes slowly for us is one of the
oldest of human observations and and
people have known that certainly
Shakespeare knew it and people you know
it's we know that time flies when you're
having fun right now we also know it a
slightly more sophisticated way that
music as an art form is capable of
wreaking havoc with your sense of time
with your perception of time that's one
of the games that music plays is
creating a sense of fast motion and slow
motion by playing with as David Eagleman
is saying there with information flow I
mean I think he's I think that's a smart
way to think about it that a way for a
psychologist to explore the perception
of time is to think in terms of how
information is processed and stored in
our brain right fine for my narrow
purposes and my time travel book I
decided I actually wasn't that
interested in the perception of time
because that part of it seemed a little
obvious to me I mean another thing that
that that we all know is that that the
years seem to pass a lot more quickly as
we get older sure you know when you're
six years old a month is a lifetime and
when you're 70 years old a month can go
spike really tragically quickly
interestingly also it seems like that
time passes more quickly in retrospect I
remember when we first had our son
everyone coming along to us and saying
oh it goes so fast you know he's gonna
grow up with an exact accent it kind of
and then they were met you know year
months and years where we were like
that's not going so fast doesn't feel
like it's going all that fat you know I
mean but they're looking back on it you
know at a vantage point of 25 years
later or whatever yeah and all of this
so so so there are a lot of things like
that but not that interesting
that are I'm not saying they're not
interesting that we kind of know and I
think it's it's it's good that there are
people who explore these things and try
to understand them better right but but
felt like a kind of side issue for me
yet obviously related because what my
book is is most fundamentally about is
our understanding of time and that's a
complicated thing very complicated thing
and that has has changed dramatically
during the last century and I guess my
point is that this all does feed into
time travel storytelling because we're
learning new things all the time about
the way time passes and the way kind of
flows and and we were therefore forced
to think about what that sentence I just
said means does time pass
does time flow I mean we're not even
getting into them much more complicated
question which obviously this
underscores of like what is time at all
and how slippery that concept is and how
aware of that we all are on some level I
actually knew that I was going to have
to deal with that question in the book
and I won't pretend that I actually
answered the question but I hope I shed
some light because I felt that that was
the time travel story trying to shed
light on that question yeah yeah indeed
I mean we have a concept of moving
across something that we don't even have
really the faintest real idea of what it
is that's pretty good whatever you say
you immediately know it's wrong if we're
moving we were moving across it or is it
moving through us or is it moving with
us are we floating in is time or River
it would be I would actually be really
interesting to simply interview a random
sampling of 500 people and ask them the
question what is time you know and hear
what they say or you could look in the
Oxford English Dictionary and and read
the you know 10,000 words they devote to
trying to answer that question I'm sure
James quick thank you so much for being
on think again this has been a fun and
as as I promised in the beginning
divergent conversations all right thank
you
it's fun for me too thanks very much and
that's it for this week's episode of
think again for those of you who are out
there and listening to the show and
enjoying what you're hearing and finding
it intellectually stimulating or you
have responses that you don't think we
addressed or whatever I'd love to hear
from you
we're big think again one word on
Twitter and I'm pretty active on there
I'm the one that runs the Twitter
account so if you shoot me a message
there unless it's extremely nasty
I will definitely respond to you I also
want to urge everybody if you haven't
done so already and probably that's the
minority among our audience but to
register to vote I am NOT crazy about
talking politics but this year I don't
think anyone in America can escape it
the stakes are very very high as far as
I'm concerned in this election and I'm
not the only one who thinks oh just go
back and listen to our episode with
Princeton historian Sean Wilentz I hope
you will register to vote and go out and
vote in this election and next week we
have a very very special guest for you
which I am going to keep under wraps
until then hope to see you then
you